من ابريل 2019 رقي الفريق محمد حمدان دقلو
الشهير بحميدتي الى رتبه فريق الاول
الثالث عشر من ابريل 2019 تم تعيينه نائبا
لرئيس المجلس العسكري الانتقالي برئاسه
الفريق اول ركن عبد الفتاح البرهان عام
عام 2021 بدا الخلاف بين البرهان وحميدتي
يظهر الى العلن حول مسار الحكم المدني 15
من ابريل 2023 تحول الصراع الى نزاع
المسلح بين قياده الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع بعد فشل الرجلين بالوصول الى
اتفاق حول الجدول الزمني لدمج الدعم
السريع بالجيش التاسع عشر من مايو 2023
اصدر البرهان مرسوما باعفاء حميدتي من
منصب نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات